[Music]
suggest uh go get busy you'll be next up
you get dominating she set back straight
and keep reading on quit at steady
dominate drop it off I'll take your
leave
okay up get up there now hurry come on
this
[Music]
I want to be a professional Cowboys from
far as I can remember since I was a
little Biddy I always going to hold that
gold buckle in my hand
my name is take a spade on the nam ten
years
[Music]
[Music]
fathers I think for the scathing father
hunter and we've got to for this food
Jewish man came along seventh battle
since I was seven now and ten and thirty
eight buckles my mom she got to be a
world champion and Pina open in the
headsman and 2008 that was really cool
and my dad wrote bowls for thirteen
years he didn't make it to the national
finals ever anymore and hauled that gold
buckle but you just don't always get to
do that
our entire family balls on Brett and I
side I've been rodeo cowboys we were
just created to be cowboys and cowgirls
make us he chose the same road that we
did but I don't necessarily know that we
honestly chose it ourselves we chose
this area because we wanted to raise
PICUs as a cowboy and we really felt
like it was still cool to be a cowboy in
Texas we were very blessed with lots of
animals we call it the funny farm around
here we have I think from him head of
cattle 235 head of cattle and I can't
forget Pegasus goats he's got a goat
herd that he started when he was a year
old
it's a great place to hang our hats and
raise our son
what did Jim I would spend on a hearse
as far as I can remember and I can't go
I remember the first time I ever did wow
I got on the horseman thank you
yeah the very first time picks was on a
horse he was two weeks old we cooking to
a high school rodeo he couldn't even
hold his own head
[Music]
yay
hey kids we decided to home-school take
us halfway through first grade our
theory was we always wanted to raise our
own kid we didn't want to leave him with
anyone else we just kind of always had
that feeling about it I suppose has was
- second - yeah oh we take a few steps
out the door to the classroom get class
taking care of it in about four hours
and then rope all afternoon every day
about 3:30 4:00 I practice and to make
it better so I can be a world champion
someday you guys want to go get it and
have to go get it and I really want to
be in one
sometimes he worries me because he is so
adult like kind of papa
sometimes that's a good thing sometimes
that's a bad thing
we you know we can't really guide him in
that direction because that's who he is
most we keep we really care
[Music]
this weekend he'll be going to the Texas
High School Rodeo Association we're
through the halfway point of the season
and pick us I think right now is leading
all around standing there's not a lot of
room for stepping your toes because
there's not a lot of their rodeos and if
your goal is to win every event and
everybody is important sometimes it's
hard being a cowboy harder is minor I
think it is
[Music]
[Music]
really a very dangerous sport anything
around animals is a dangerous sport
you just have no control over some of
the things that they do
[Music]
we had a lot of chances to get hurt
especially kind of step off and you
might step throwing my chair your knee
[Music]
here run you over taking you step on you
throw you up in there basically don't
slow down the same time
[Music]
you
[Music]
- oldest we tried to teach him and we've
always tried to teach him how to ride
correctly and how to be in control of
his animal because they're an animal we
rodeo about every weekend this weekend
he gets on two Spears and he needed to
just make sure he's in tune a little bit
and make sure that he practices you're
stopping halfway through steroid insulin
I feel I can't get butterflies in but if
you use it in the right way you can make
good out of it so nasty right and I
guess he is taking a little break that's
been from about two months since he's
been on any skiers here stop take me and
then it kicked my ankle and rolled up in
dirt to me it looked like a broken ankle
the way it just stepped on a sideways
like that
I got him some ice and he put it on
there he finished this event up that day
he had a little bit of black and blue in
there but it wasn't that bad of an
injury candy okay Hey look slowly all
the way back over buckle and throw your
body like this and then you'll be facing
that way can't get off next and I'll
kick you like I get that
yes exactly you want a rope keV yeah
okay then you gotta get off your shoes
good
yeah there you go that's what I'm
talking about give me five
I don't care if you didn't land you're
still going that way don't matter you
see what I'm saying
okay my favorite is in the sky don't
open it's just cuz such a rush and I
always like it sometimes little baby go
knock them up
square them up square them up move them
over I am a worrywart I don't like to
watch a lot of the things that happen
first
I like Brett to go take him because I
would make pay kiss afraid you're ready
blood son
[Music]
here you know when she's going that's
the reason why my dad like bored I did I
don't know one went crazy man and how
mind goes in the castle swinging
[Music]
it's wrong come on the card there you go
hello we tried to really practice at our
house just like we're gonna rope with
the rodeos or right at the road yeah
yeah yeah I've got a wire make sure that
you speak out my own strangest-looking
it pull it in your did you hit on the
dummy okay all right kiss it like it's
over I'm sincere Ponyta when he was
small I think some people thought that
we pushed him to do it but he's pushed
us he's made us better at what we do
because his 1/2 of it gets us out there
more there's days that pretty tired
after work and I'd like to maybe just
relax one day but then I know I mean
Pegasus Tammy is only going to be at
home eight more years I better spend
every second I can my ride the physician
K practice watch the feet when you lose
her
[Music]
being a cowboy it's a must and it's not
a maybe or what if it's a must it's the
best feeling ever to watch him do
something that he hadn't been able to do
before when you actually see him do what
you told him to do it's like ah think
you do this you got this step we can
we're going up to Fort Worth to compete
in some rodeos finish goodbye
[Music]
Friday night we're going to the cow town
coffee I'm in the Fort Worth Stockyards
Celia take us are entered in the
breakaway or open so he's gonna get
sticky
I don't worry about I guess I know that
he has been taught he's been trained
can't be afraid because when you're
afraid a lot that's the time when it
happened she grew up rodeo and that's
all I want to be
[Music]
[Music]
we usually try to say a prayer before
every time that we compete
[Music]
we pray for ourselves in our animal your
odds were very very low when you get
Saturday you have an animal that you're
on an animal that you're trying to catch
for an animal you're trying to ride your
odds are very slim we don't expect I
just to win every time you go somewhere
he's just like everyone else
it's kind of so like maybe I didn't get
it done I could have done it but I just
didn't do it
if you're blessed to have a great rodeo
great if not you have to learn how to
rebound from it the losing factor
because what we call it when you come
home and you're not the champion you
want to work so much harder because you
know that's the only way that you're
going to get better this weekend rodeo a
few months to win in the year-end it's
important today the rodeo extra high
school junior high and first the fifth
grade is nice and um be any they don't
compete at the state or national level
but they get to compete at the regional
level against other kids first or fifth
grade
Pecos or tied Spears health team Roku do
some tie-down roping some breakaway
roping he's in the top three in every
standings and he's first in all around
so he knew Cisco have a consistent rodeo
and have lots of fun and he should stay
where he's at in the standings okay get
up ya know League birthday when you
driving up so my finger this video and
then wait for support
hey I think you won the first go my good
red perfect setup there she need to work
on looking over your shoulder and
getting off just a little bit better on
this next one and dominate the next one
next will be break lawyer alpha and then
go time and then I'm done
have fun put on the syrup and be
aggressive yeah yeah I like to me when
one and dad proud of me just good oh
let's go tiny might stumble or if you're
adult might go under your horses chest
and then they get all crazy in my face
flip over just all kinds of things
happen yeah you open for them monitor
unit
you're doing the only Mexican onion
sponge people they like yeah I made a
good run it gives me more of a drive to
want to go get it harder to want to go
win more yeah versus you know he really
is a great cowboy not just because he's
mine and Brett's child he puts his heart
into it and his take is decided tomorrow
but he didn't want to be a cowboy and he
wanted to play basketball we would be
his number-one fans on the way home he's
already climbing and going oh we gonna
get home in time where I could go out
there and so today we're like no and
tomorrow you're gonna take the day off -
no I can't I need to get out there and
practice
rodeo is not a sport to me it's a
lifestyle it evolved from real cowboys
as we call me
and I feel like we really need to be
true to our roots and remember that it
comes real special to be a cowboy
convect achievement ever is a gold
buckle holding those gold buckles you
know a lot of people have them hopefully
someday I'd like to hold one of those
gold buckles in my hands and call for
him
[Music]
[Music]
God sent me here to be accounting
and the first thing in lady told me said
when you rode in arena he said
everybody's eyes are on you she said
half of them wanted you to win the other
half don't give a damn whether you win
or not because it's calling your skin
but I'll always want to win I've been a
professional cowboy since 1959 dealing
with racism back in the 50s and six and
now it's still kind of hard people would
see me at a rodeo and because I was of a
different color they thought I was
working for somebody
people want to know a lot of times why
did you want to be a castle well I had
seen a lot of black Cowboys judged
improperly but in the calf Ropin I knew
that I wasn't going to be judged by a
human I was going to be judged by the
clock the clock was going to determine
whether I get any money or not right now
all I do is put on Cowboys of color
rodeo cowboys of color features Indians
blacks Hispanics and white cowboy was
also
black Cowboys in the history [ __ ] is
damn near forgotten very many people
don't even realize that New Mexico was
in discolored Bob Blackman Chicago was
founded by blackness I don't care what
color you are these are the kind of
things that we want young people to know
I have four boys they are all
professional Cowboys my grand daughter
Rachel Hearn this was her first big
rodeo so it's a way of life uh I'm 76
years old
that's pretty darn old for cowboy it's
in my blood I think the day that I lay
down and can't breathe anymore I'll
still be looking for a radio the horses
really do help you with progression once
you own a horse and you out that's all
your mind is on is having fun
my name is Shai here and I'm a concrete
I would
I first got on a horse
after I turned ten and I was young so I
was like I like that word I thought it
was cool
or should I return we're just like that
man Shadle had to combine our tempers
and work together because she's the walk
wire while I was running but those
people off and I always beat back on her
just ahead of patient when I ride people
actually give me like drops and they
actually be applauding me the hood guys
and everything baby actually can I ride
you want tree even like it when the
stable started about ten years ago it
gave me something to do something to
keep the kids busy with keep them
occupied from running the street get in
trouble and Southwest Philadelphia is a
lot of stuff's worth killing and I try
to give kids something to get away from
stuff like that and when they start
learning with the animals it kind of
calmed down because they teaching we
learning it helps them out a lot
a Protestant community is crazy I don't
know a brother uncle lost a lot of
friends but when I work with the horse
is like a type of therapy I can have fun
and not worry about everything else
that's going on around ya I would have
never met Malik and fed around horses I
probably would and doing stuff that I
was supposed to be don't get in trouble
once you get to running and having fun
it seems like all that is forgotten
you
[Music]